how's it going bros mate it's less than
a month to Christmas how does that make
you feel good
sad I don't care I'm just kidding of
course I do
sorry that happens every time I try to
be sincere during Christmas there's
always a struggle of someone gives you a
gift that you don't really like so you
have to give them back something but you
don't know what but don't worry I got
your brother back
I listed five things that you can give
people that you kind of don't feel like
giving gifts to people gift number one
bonkers be sorry gift number one a
bonking cheap it says here it never gets
headaches it will never call a taxi in
the middle of the night I don't
understand what that means the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ]
if you have a friend who you think might
be into this kind of shape
there you go
that's great I'll have fun with you
later [ __ ] a great gift can be gifted
to anyone your mom the next item is New
York Times bestseller book 50 shades of
chicken mm-hmm let me read a passage for
you birds he pulls me off the device
frees my ankles and lays me gently on a
bed of potatoes my legs and bend a
little and my juices flow over my golden
glowing skin oh you look beautiful like
this chicken Oh chicken you're so ready
I think this is a great gift in general
and it's basically a boyfriend pillow so
what you do is you can sleep and cuddle
with like it's your boyfriend
I never cuddled with a boyfriend but I
imagine this is at least 95 percent
accurate Oh senpai tell me about my but
it won't make love to you but it will
keep you warm at night great gift like I
should demonstrate here with the
butthole
you can fist your cheap ma man open up
oh it's a very tender bottle you can
probably just finger ate this gift might
not think of that interesting because
you're absolutely right and I think this
fits a gift someone who just isn't
and interesting or maybe someone you
just don't like in general I don't know
we also have okay Oh God
Oh oh it feels so good yeah next
oh it doesn't even smell nice who came
up with this [ __ ] literally I can't I'm
sorry that's that's actually kind of
hilarious it's actually a soap alright
that's that's kind of a funny gift
actually but anyway I hope you bros
learned something new here today if you
have any other great suggestions leave
it and leave them in the comments and I
will check them out maybe like if you
enjoyed this video brother have fun
checking out these items with you and as
always stay awesome bro